Mark ist schon wieder unterwegs.
Australien.
Wo ist denn Bina da?
Ich würd auch gern mal wieder
in Urlaub.
Wann war ich eigentlich das letzte
Mal nett essen?
Ein Esel!
Fear of missing out.
Kurz FOMO.
So nennt man die Angst,
etwas zu verpassen.
Die Angst, dass deine Freunde
ohne dich Spaß haben.
Vielleicht sogar mehr Spaß,
als wenn du dabei wärst?
Die Angst, dass auf einer Party,
die du verpasst,
der shit passiert,
über den alle reden,
und du nicht mitreden kannst.
Das FOMO-Phänomen ist in unserer
Generation so präsent geworden,
dass es einige Psychologen zum
Forschungsteam erklärt haben.
Allen voran der Psychologe Pribi...
Prizzi...
Przybylski?
Der folgenden psychologischen
Evaluationsbogen
namens FOMO-Scale entwarf.
1. Ich habe Angst,
dass andere tollere Sachen
erleben als ich.
2. Ich habe Angst,
dass meine Freunde tollere Sachen
erleben als ich.
3. Ich mache mir einen Kopf, wenn
meine Freunde ohne mich Spaß haben.
4. Ich krieg die Krise,
wenn ich nicht weiß,
was meine Freunde gerade tun.
5. Es ist mir wichtig,
Insider-Witze meiner Freunde
zu verstehen.
6. Manchmal frage ich mich,
ob ich zu viel Zeit damit verbringe,
immer auf dem Laufenden zu sein.
7. Ich finde es schlimm,
wenn ich eine Gelegenheit verpasse,
meine Freunde zu treffen.
8. Wenn ich Spaß habe
oder eine tolle Erfahrung mache,
dann möchte ich sie auch
online teilen.
9. Wenn ich ein geplantes Treffen
verpasse,
dann stört mich das ziemlich.
10. Wenn ich im Urlaub bin, halte ich
mich auf dem Laufenden über das,
was
meine Freunde zu Hause machen.
Wenn ihr dem Großteil dieser Aussagen
stark zustimmt,
dann leidet ihr wahrscheinlich
an FOMO.
Ich habe euch den Fragebogen
unten auch noch mal verlinkt.
Da könnt ihr euch zum Spaß testen.
Eine korrekte wissenschaftliche
Auswertung ist da aber nicht dabei.
Diese Fragen werden in
psychologischen Studien
immer wieder verwendet.
Um das Ausmaß der FOMO festzuhalten.
Psychologen sind sich einig:
FOMO und Social Media
gehören ganz klar zusammen.
Früher war es gar nicht
so leicht, herauszufinden,
was die Freunde ständig machen.
Heute wird man nicht nur täglich
damit konfrontiert.
Sondern jeder stellt sich
auf Social Media besonders toll da.
# Blessed.
Echt interessant,
wie sich die Zeiten ändern.
Bei meiner Recherche hierfür
bin ich auf eine
Studie von 1998 gestoßen.
Die bringt Internet-Sucht
mit Depressionen in Verbindung.
Süß. Damals wussten sie noch nicht,
was Internet-Sucht wirklich ist.
Seit es die hier gibt, muss man
Internet-Sucht neu definieren.
* Klaviermusik *
Früher konnte man
an einem Samstagabend
in Jogginghose auf der Couch sitzen
und sein Leben genießen.
Heute sitzt man Samstagabend auf der
Couch mit einem schlechten Gewissen.
Weil alle Freunde anscheinend
ein viel spannenderes Leben haben.
Als man selbst.
Es ist nur noch nicht ganz klar,
ob Social Media FOMO vorantreibt,
oder ob FOMO die Nutzung
von Social Media verstärkt.
Was denkt ihr?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
FOMO ist analog zu sozialer
Ausgrenzung.
Warum das so schlimm ist,
das wissen Neurologen.
Die haben beobachtet,
dass bei sozialer Ausgrenzung
die selben Gehirnsregionen aktiviert
werden wie bei physischem Schmerz.
Außerdem wurde FOMO mit einem
geringeren Selbstbewusstsein,
geringerer Selbstzufriedenheit
und einem allgemein schlechteren
Gemütszustand in Verbindung gebracht.
Was kann man jetzt dagegen machen?
Wenn ihr Tipps habt,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Wir jedenfalls machen
jetzt 2 Wochen Sommerpause.
Wir sind am 17. August
wieder für euch da.
D.h., die nächsten 2 Wochen
könnt ihr zumindest auf diesem Kanal
nichts verpassen.
Beruhigend, oder?
Schönschlau.
Untertitel: ARD Text im Auftrag
von Funk (2017)
Wie schlimm ist eure FOMO?
Macht den Test.
Und schreibt mir euren Score.
Mein Score ist 6.
D.h., ich hab keine besonders
ausgeprägte FOMO. Zum Glück.
Wir sehen uns nach der Sommerpause in
2 Wochen. Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.